President Trump is getting some praise
from some unusual quarters when it comes
to North Korea well the same is true
regarding his decision to slap tariffs
on imported steel and aluminum tonight
chief congressional correspondent Mike
Emanuel looks at how Big Labor is siding
with this Republican president steel is
steel you don't have steel you don't
have a country the images were striking
a Republican president with a largely
conservative agenda surrounded by union
workers who traditionally support
Democrats it didn't end there the steel
and aluminum union members praised the
president for standing up for workers it
was very sincere about you know helping
the still workers out and we emphasized
you know our struggles and one aluminum
worker says his facilities only
operating at about 40 percent capacity
that says the president's signature
should have an immediate impact but
these tariffs going into place this
gives us ability to come back to 100
percent capacity investing over 100
million dollars to our plant and over
300 some odd jobs will be brought back
to the communities top union leaders
also talked about this president trying
to level the playing field for American
workers I do applaud this administration
for having the courage to levy tariffs
to stop the cheating and United
Steelworkers International President Leo
Gerard said by ensuring supplies and
capacity for steel and aluminum mr.
Trump quote took decisive action to
support national security a big change
from when Gerard spoke at a Labor Day
2016 event in Pittsburgh supporting
Hillary Clinton not once was the great
savior Donald Trump ever called up and
said I'm really upset that you guys are
losing these steel mills to these
Chinese is there anything I can do to
help the president's tariffs made a lot
of congressional Republicans very
uncomfortable because they view the
measures as a tax but that same action
may make some Democrats nervous if it
causes union workers to see this
president as looking out for them breath
alright Mike thank you